unsere vorfahren haben sich gegenseitig
aufgegessen und forschungsteams weltweit
rätseln schon seit langer zeit ob dies
am nahrungsmangel lag oder aber ob
kulturelle und soziale gründe eine rolle
spielten experten und expertinnen aus
spanien haben jetzt endlich eine antwort
auf diese frage parat und ihre
erkenntnisse sind wirklich mehr als
gruselig klicks zum science fiction
täglich faszinierendes science videos
abonniert den kanal nur dann verpasst
ihr nichts herzlich willkommen
[Musik]
das spanische forschungsteam hatte
fossilien aus der gran dolina höhle
nördlich der stadt burgos genauer
analysiert diese stammen vom romand
essor der vor rund 900.000 jahren lebte
die bezeichnung bedeutet so viel wie
vorläufer des anatomisch modernen
menschen
fest steht jedenfalls dass vertreter des
homo an des source den gesamten körper
ihrer toten mit menschen verzehrt haben
das spanische forschungsteam entdeckte
jetzt nämlich eindeutige anzeichen für
die kannibalistische praxis dazu
ressorts rodrigues einer der beteiligten
forscher die menschlichen körper wurden
gehäutet ausgeweitet und entband die
langen knochen wurden zerbrochen um an
das knochenmark so gelang zudem sind auf
mehreren menschlichen und tierischen
überresten bissspuren dokumentiert die
experten und expertinnen gehen aufgrund
der muster der schäden davon aus dass
unsere vorfahren nicht nur die
rippenknochen ihre artgenossen angekaut
und an gelutscht haben sondern den toten
körper mitsamt dem gehirn und den
organen gegessen haben ein echt
gruseliges mal und das gehörte wohl vor
knapp einer million jahren zum alltag
dieser frühen menschen
doch warum genau fest steht bislang nur
dass der kannibalismus zur
menschheitsgeschichte gehört und eine
alte weit verbreitete praxis ist manche
fachleute gehen davon aus dass dies an
sozialen und kulturellen gründen lag
oder lassen sie sich ganz einfach
gegenseitig auf um ihren kalorienbedarf
zu decken
dagegen aber spricht dass diese frühen
menschen keinesfalls an nahrungsmangel
litten das verraten tier knochen die in
derselben fundschicht zahlreich
vorhanden sind deswegen denen die
spanischen fachleute nicht davon aus
dass unsere vorfahren aufgrund von
hunger zum menschenfresser wurden ihrer
berechnung zufolge hätten wohl 20
gruppen angehörige drei monate lang
allein durch die tiere mit einer
ausreichenden essens menge versorgt
werden können zudem zeigt das verhältnis
der aufgespürten menschenknochen zur
tier knochen dass die frühen menschen
absichtlich andere frühe menschen als
ihr essen auswählten und zwar aus einem
grund die jungen menschlichen opfer
waren die lohnendste beute viel leichter
zu erbeuten als hirscher oder nashörner
zu diesen gruseligen ergebnis kamen dass
spanische forschungsteam durch die
anwendung eines klassischen beute waren
modells auf die knochenfunde von gran
dolina demnach werden tiere oder
menschen eben die beute die zum einen
die meiste energie liefert und zum
anderen mit dem kleinsten aufwand zu
erbeuten ist como antes es war also ein
kannibale weil sich das am meisten lohnt
erklärt ist damit aber noch nicht wie
die opfer zu tode kamen wurden sie bei
konflikten getötet und dann als nahrung
konsumiert ähnlich wie bei schimpansen
oder wurden die opfer einfach durch
einen frühen natürlichen tod zur
mahlzeit dazu heißt es in der studie
die einfachste erklärung könnte sein
dass diese opfer zur gleichen gruppe wie
die kannibalen gehörten und eines
natürlichen todes sterben
ethnographische daten sprechen für diese
erklärung denn demnach sterben bei jäger
und sammler völkern bis zu 65 prozent
der stammesangehörigen bevor sie
überhaupt das erwachsenenalter erreichen
höchstwahrscheinlich machte hohmann
tessa also das beste aus dem frühen tod
seiner art genossen und nutzte diese als
zusätzliche nahrung ist planet der affen
realistisch und jetzt kommen die drei us
anklicken darauf anschauen und astor
comics tv abonnieren bis dann bleib dran